Greetings, Salon.
This is Mohsen Banon, I am a software and internet engineer.
The title of this presentation is "About Blee".
Blee stands for "By Star Liber Halal Imax Environment".
In this presentation, I want to look at Imax as a primary ingredient for the usage environment
of an autonomy and morality-directed digital ecosystem.
My focus here is not just Imax.
This is about augmenting Imax in the context of our own specific digital ecosystem.
This presentation is part theoretical and part practical.
I spend about half of my time on the theory and the bigger picture.
The second half is hands-on and Imax's century.
Imax has long been recognized as the ultimate integration platform, enabling the creation
of an unparalleled user environment.
Tomohiro is right on the mark when he says, "The reason why Imax's platform is good is
that it cooperates with OS, not because it's good by itself."
But this recognition has often been in the context of a generic and abstract OS.
So I am updating Matsumaya's observation as, "The reason why Imax's platform is good
is that it facilitates creation of specific integrated usage environments, like Blee,
which cooperates with Debian and Bysos as part of the Liber Halal Bistor digital ecosystem."
Imax is an especially good choice as the universal core of usaving environments of a digital
ecosystem, because it has an incredibly powerful display engine and an incredibly powerful
ellipse engine, and an incredibly powerful input methods engine, and an incredibly powerful
common agent's paradigm, and the very rich set of mature and convivial idioms and memes
for absorption and integration of external software services continuum capabilities.
In our model, we first augment Imax with a set of cohesive ellipse capabilities and create
Blee, Bistor Liber Halal Imax's environment.
We then further enhance Blee with an integrated framework on top of Debian called Bysos, by
store internet services operating system. Blee is inherently intertwined and integrated
with Bysos. This combination of universal Bysos and Blee then forms a foundation for the
creation of an autonomy-directed digital ecosystem that we call Bysos.
Over the past two decades, I have been working on creating a comprehensive interdisciplinary
and non-properiatory digital ecosystem. We call it Bysos. Bysos challenges the existing
proprietary American digital ecosystem while operating concurrently alongside it.
Bysos' primary offerings are tangible autonomy and genuine privacy on a very large scale.
Bysos is about re-decentralization of internet application services. The store in Bysos stands
for Unix's gloving symbol, signifying that our scope is everything. Blee is a bigger and
different vision for Imax. Let's compare and contrast what I'm proposing against common
current practices of the Imax culture. Please permit me to be slightly cynical.
Much of what we have been seeing in the Imax culture and in Imax Conf can be characterized
as stories of tunnel vision engineers, scratching various issues by integrating various capabilities
and providing DIY recipes. Imax and Lisb are so powerful that people have come up with
catch phrases like the Curse of Lisb. The Curse is that the power of Lisb breeds individualism.
If you can be so powerful alone, you work longer alone. Because it's easy to spin your
own whatever library many people do. I'm suggesting that we should raise the bar. Let's cultivate
Imax in the context of our own digital ecosystem instead. Do more and do more outside of Imax
and recognize that a well-integrated smaller Imax leads to a better usage environment.
Broadly speaking, digital ecosystems are viewed as consisting of four parts. Ideology
software services and content. Software services and content are poly-existentials and can
be analyzed from three different aspects, functionality, usage and the manner of existence.
By manner of existence of poly-existentials, we mean everything relating to how the
poly-existential exists within society. This includes, for example,
or poly-existentials internally transparent. Societal ideology determines
manner of software services and content and in turn manner of existence of software services
and content impact society. In the American model, loss of privacy and autonomy are direct
consequences of the IPR regime. Based on this characterization, let's consider these three
digital ecosystems, the proprietary American digital ecosystem, force and by store.
The five big American proprietary tech companies, Google, Microsoft, Apple, Facebook and Amazon,
have created five competing enclaves as mostly separate and isolated digital ecosystem.
In this slide, I'm focusing on the first three and each of their OSs, their usage environment
and their clouds. Let's clearly recognize that the economic model of these proprietary digital
ecosystems is surveillance capitalism. Now, let's focus on the right side of this picture.
On the non-properatory side, based on the first model, we have ended up with lots of components.
We have Debian as a platform. We have Emacs as an editor-centered usage environment,
but on the non-properatory side, we don't have anything that can reasonably be considered
a digital ecosystem. I mean, the services aspect is missing.
By store, aspires to be a complete non-properatory digital ecosystem.
We were all born into the belief system of intellectual property rights,
making it exceedingly difficult for us to even imagine that this foundational ownership framework
could be fundamentally flawed. I am delighted to announce the availability of my recent book,
Nature of Polyexistent Shows. The full title of my book is Nature of Polyexistent Shows,
basis for abolishment of the Western intellectual property rights regime,
and introduction of the Liber Hallal by store digital ecosystem.
Now, let's know how users of know how ideas, formulas, software and information are inherently
non-scars. They are polyexistent Shows. Unlike mono-existent Shows, which exist in singular,
polyexistent Shows naturally exist in multiples. What is abundant in nature is being made
artificially scarce through man-made ownership rules called copyright and patents.
Let me provide a brief overview. This book is divided into five parts,
each representing a layer of interest to you and to our societal policy makers.
Part one, the philosophical layer, delves into the concept of polyexistence.
In this part, I introduce, for the very first time, the concept and terminology of polyexistent Shows.
The topic of restriction of polyexistent Shows and the Western IPR is one and the same.
Comprehending polyexistence invalidates the Western IPR model. We are living inside of an ownership
fallacy. The Western IPR regime is a sin of our times. Part two is the pathology layer.
Over the course of the past two centuries, numerous theories have been proposed to justify
intellectual property. In this part, I offer my perspective on the weaknesses inherent
in each of these theories. Part three, the ethics layer, focuses on contours of cures.
Having dismissed the Western intellectual property rights regime as an erroneous governance
model for polyexistent Shows, I propose the Lieber Hallal model of governance of polyexistent Shows
towards facilitating conviviality of tools. Part four, the engineering layer introduces the Lieber
Hallal by Spur digital ecosystem as an ethical alternative to the prevailing proprietary American
digital ecosystem. Part five, the sociology layer delves into formulation of Lieber Hallal oriented
societal policies. It's evident that the abolishment of intellectual property carries significant
consequences. In this part, I present my thoughts on this particular dimension for Eastern societies.
For Western societies, I confine myself to inside of IPR strategies.
You can think of this book as being in two volumes. Our focus is Blee in volume two.
But as our blueprint needs to be interdisciplinary, there are some key concepts of volume one
that I want to briefly discuss here. Volume one deals with the general concept of polyexistence
and in validity of IPR. In chapter 11, I introduce the very sensitive and potent vocabulary
of Hallal and Lieber Hallal. Volume two is backed by software and internet services. Content of this
book belongs to all of humanity and verbatim copying of it is unrestricted. If you want to read it,
this book is yours. The nature of polyexistentials book is available both online and in print.
This book is available as two editions, the US edition and the international edition.
The US edition is written with a slightly milder Western unfriendly tone, while the international edition
includes additional original content in foresee. I consider the international edition
to be the authoritative version. However, many readers in the US and Western countries
may prefer the US edition. I maintain separate Git repositories for each edition on GitHub.
US edition is BXPLPC12033 and international edition is BXPLPC12074.
Cloning these repositories will give you access to the book in PDF format, suitable for both
A4 and US letter printing and in EPUB format. Alternatively, the content can be downloaded directly
from your browser without needing to clone the repositories. To ensure broader online availability
and stability, I have also published the book on Zenodo, complete with the UI digital object identifier.
You can download both the A4 and 8.5 by 11 PDFs from there as well.
The book is also available in print on Amazon and most major bookstores in the US and Western regions.
The ISBNs for both editions are included in this slide. Additionally,
I have published this book in Iran through Djangal publishers. I did not write this book for profit.
My aim is to share my thoughts and encourage readers to engage with my views and ideas.
Your feedback is welcome and I'm genuinely interested in hearing your perspectives.
In Western markets, I have priced the print edition somewhat above production costs.
If you find the value in the book and the by store project, purchasing a copy will help support
my work. Thanks in advance for your support. And here are the same links as a native reveal slide.
If instead of a video you are viewing this presentation as a reveal web page,
you can just click on the pointers and URLs.
The concept of poly-existentials has not appeared in prior discussions of validity of IPR.
Once you start thinking in terms of mono-existence and poly-existence,
the recognition of illegitimacy of Western IPR becomes very simple.
I want to very quickly give you a taste of that. You can of course dig deeper in the book.
Existence and possession are aspects of nature, ownership or man-made rules.
All material objects exist in singular and are mono-existentials.
For mono-existentials things are simple. Mono-existentials say paper exists in singular.
It naturally has a single processor. A single owner can be assigned to it, which then makes that
single possession lawful. Poly-existentials naturally exist in multiples.
Much of our world is actually a mixture of mono-existentials and poly-existentials,
which we call mixed-existentials.
Possession and of poly-existentials is naturally many to many. Without any conflict,
poly-existentials can have many processors. Poly-existentials are inherently non-ravalry.
The requirement for ownership to be in harmony with the nature of possession and existence
is violated by the Western IPR regime, which assigns a single owner to what exists
and is possessed in multiples. The end result is creation of artificial scarcity.
Ramification of ownership mistakes are usually catastrophic. Consider the previous
Western and American ownership mistake, that of American slavery, ownership of Africans
by Americans and Europeans. See Chapter 7, Western slavery and the Western IPR regime
of the book for some parallels between these mistakes. This time with the Western IPR ownership
mistake, all of humanity is in danger. So, how are we to correct this catastrophic mistake?
The strategies of public licenses and false are not sufficient. These are minor band-aids. We need
to do a lot more. We need to understand what we are going to replace the mistaken Western IPR
regime with. My answer is Liber Halal Governance of Poly-existentials. Much of my book revolves
around that. We need to fully reject ownership of poly-existentials and replace it with attribution
machineries towards just rewards. We need to abolish the artificial scarcity
of poly-existentials that the Western IPR regime has created and restore poly-existentials
back to their natural state, that of non-rival-ruse public goods.
By now, many Western-as and many West-toxicated are thinking, these are empty slogans that are going
nowhere. And they are right. Copyright and patents are fully entrenched in the West. But what about
the rest of the world? What about the Chinese, the Iranians, Brazilians, Cubans and the rest?
The intellectual property rights regime is not universal. There is more to the world than the West.
What if the WTO was to be recognized for what it is, the Western trade organization?
Thus far, I have been discussing the nature of all poly-existentials, any formula, in any form.
Next, I want to turn our attention to digitals in general and software in particular.
Software is a very special form of poly-existentials. Software is immediately useful, software
produces tools. Digital, as text, music, video, etc. are a pure form of poly-existentials that are
controlled by software. As developers, we know well that we can best produce good software through
collaboration. In that collaborative model, the software itself performs a collaborative road.
Software functions as a vessel for accumulation of our expert component contributions.
The Western IPR model cultivates artificial scarcities and competition.
But software developers instinctly recognize the superiority of the natural collaborative model.
Through public licenses, software developers have done a Juditsu on the IPR model
and have created a collaborative framework inside of the copyright model.
Based on that, natural public goods have defeated artificial scarcity.
Our success with software is proof that the entirety of the Western IPR regime is flawed.
The profession of software engineers need to create a relationship with society.
We need to demand for societal rules which establish proper manner of existence of software
and internet application services. In return, based on that, we should fulfill our guardianship role
and make sure that autonomy and privacy are preserved and that practice digital ecosystems
are healthy. To get there, we need to come up with the right label that represents the proper
manner of existence of software. Those four, two labels have appeared on the scene,
free software and open source. I'm saying that both are problematic.
Free software is ill-directed. It is based on the model of granting users,
freedoms that are irrelevant to most software users. Perhaps copy left or ethical software
could have been better labels. Open source is a moral compromise. It rejects the requirement for
perpetuity of copy left. It facilitates convergence of corporate interest and surrogate activities
of software developers. Over time, proprietary corporations, too, have come to recognize
the superiority of the collaborative model. These proprietary corporations then derailed the
original intent that all software should always remain open source. With permissive public licenses
which permit open source becoming proprietary, the intent of open source has been marginalized
and permissive open source has become the norm. I expand on all of this in chapter 12, digital
non-properatory movements. Instead of free software and open source, the label that I introduce
is Lieberhalol. The Lieberhalol label is distinct and different from false labels.
As an inside of IPR strategy, the Lieberhalol label maps to a single public license, the AferoGPR.
In the Lieberhalol model, it's not up to the developer to choose their own licenses.
There's only one correct license that conveys the Lieberhalol manner of existence of software.
Also, unlike the false labels that dance around the validity of the Western IPR regime,
the Lieberhalol label recognizes the invalidity of the Western IPR regime, calls for
a "bollishment of the Western IPR" and suggests various outside of IPR strategies.
C. Part 5 Formulation of Societal Policies for Details
Furthermore, unlike false, which is just software-oriented, the Lieberhalol label goes
beyond software and also applies to internet application services.
In many ways, software is yesterday's news. Much of what we are experiencing today
is in the form of internet application services.
Internet application services provide remote access to execution of software.
As such, much of false has become proprietary internet application services, as AferoGPR is rarely used.
This is why the Lieberhalol definitions and labels span software and internet application services.
Based on the interdisciplinary state setting that the nature of poly-existentials
book provided and the by-store blueprint that we reviewed, we can now focus on Blee.
Think of Blee as a layer on top of Emacs and think of by-source as a layer on top of DBA.
Let's bootstrap raw-by-source and raw-blee. Starting from scratch, get yourself a fresh copy of DBA and 12.
Then go to github.com/bxgenesis-start.
The readmeat.org file at that github repo is same as chapter 18 of the book.
We will next run raw-by-source.chelle. But prior to that, let's take a quick look.
This bootstrap script will do a lot as root on your fresh DBA. It's best to first try it on a
disposable VM. Raw-by-source.sh adds the current DBA user to sudoes. Then it installs ppex.
And then with ppex, it installs from pypi by-source.provision.
By-source.provision includes additional batch scripts that are then executed.
Full installation involves setting up various accounts, group various directory hierarchies,
lots of up packages, and lots of Python packages. From the by-source name space.
If you're ready, copy and paste this line, and run it. You will be prompted for the root
password. Then be patient. Full installation can take 15 minutes or so. The logs of this script are
captured in raw-by-source.datetag.log.org. What has been installed on your system or raw-by-source
and raw-bly? The universality of DBA let's us build on by-source and bleed, both in the usage
environment and the service environment. With EMAX 3D now available on Android, and with termux
up packages infrastructure in place, it will be very viable to port by-source and bleed to Android.
We have not done so yet. We're waiting for EMAX 3D to mature up. This is by-source mobile
second strategy. Upon completion of the bootstrapping process, you end up with raw-by-source and
raw-bly. You then need to re-log in. At which point your notice that a new account called by-store
has been created. By-store is the default usage account. Let's log into it. You will see a customized
by-store GNOME desktop. You will also notice a bleed startup icon. Let's use it and start
bleed. Notice that the EMAX splash screen has been replaced, and also note that this splash screen
is an org mode. All the original EMAX splash screen info is kept under about EMAX.
Let me enlarge the screen. Now we can live inside of bleed. Notice that the top drop-down EMAX
menus have been augmented. Everything to the left of the file menu is new. Notice the panels menu.
More on these later. Now let me get myself a shell and run tail/set-zip password.
Notice that a number of new accounts has been created. Notably by-source, by-store, and BPO-delimiter.
Let's next CD-to-by-source. Everything related to by-source is in here. The rest is as DBN was.
Let's take a look at /by-source-glie-nf3. All the e-list code for bleed is in here.
For now, bleed is layered on top of Doom. Robby-source and Robly are starting points. They are meant to be
customized. Let's next see how that is done. Robby-source and Robly are foundational layers. They
can be augmented in a variety of ways. The basic unit in the by-store model is the autonomous
site. Think of the autonomous site as the totality of computing and communication capabilities
in a modern family home, plus the ability of that family to host their own internet application
services. Let's walk through how Robby-source and Robly are used to construct an autonomous site.
By-source augmentation model is based on by-source capability bundles, BCBs. Robby-source can be
augmented to become a virtual machine hosting service. From there on, we can use reproducible
images to implement the infrastructure of sites. Took key services are the site BPO GitLab server
and site registrars. With these in place, we can facilitate self-hosting,
which in the by-source model is called possession-assertable liver services. These topics and these
concepts are described in Chapter 17, technology of by-store, by-source. The concepts of service
portability, service possession assertion, autonomous site and inner outer and exposed to
rims of autonomous site or fundamental to by-store. These are shown in this figure as network
abodes. Chapter 17 of the book provides more details. Blee introduces a number of new concepts
that augment EMAX. Some of these are intertwined with by-source and by-store, but some are not.
Here, I provide some examples of these new general concepts. We love EMAX and we love Unix
because their design is convivial. By convivial, I'm referring to Ivan Illich's concept and
terminology of tools for conviviality. It was first published in 1973. It's a must read. A goal
of the design of the by-store digital ecosystem is to enlarge aggregated conviviality.
Here, let's start by reviewing the idioms and means that have made EMAX and Unix so very convivial
and some of the key idioms that have augmented them over the years. I'm showing them as
Linux++ and EMAX++. For the most part, these two philosophies have not been combined.
They were developed and have evolved mostly separately. Think of by-source idioms as an extension
of Linux++ idioms and think of BLEE idioms as an extension of EMAX++.
Then intertwined by-source and BLEE. This aggregated convivial tools powers by-store.
Let me first explain what I mean by aggregated convivial tools and then let me give some examples.
Here is a key sentence from Elyche's tools for conviviality in 1973 essay.
Convivial tools are those which give each person who uses them the greatest opportunity to enrich
the environment with the fruits of his or her vision.
Preparatory manner of existence of software makes them industrial.
Liber Halal Manerov existence of software is a prerequisite for conviviality.
The concept of org dynamic blocks is very powerful but why should they be primarily used in org mode?
I say let's generalize them to EMAX dynamic blocks. Have defaults for org-deblogs start
or E in every relevant mode and use them everywhere. BLEE does that.
In programming languages, dynamic blocks can be used as visible macros.
For those of us who live inside of EMAX, enhancing programming with org mode capabilities is awesome,
incredibly awesome. This can be done in two ways. One with literate programming and org
Babel and two with traditional surrounded programming and Comiga. Comiga stands for collaborative
org mode enhanced EMAX generalized authorship. It's just an acronym that I have come up with.
Literate programming and org Babel are well established. There is a related talk in EMAX
Conf 2024 titled literate programming for the 21st century. Comiga is the inverse of org Babel.
I prepare Comiga over org Babel because I prefer traditional surrounded programming over literate
programming. To each is on. This is not about that debate. This is about mixing your programming
mode with org mode. Much of BLEE and BISOS are implemented in Comiga. Almost all of our E list
python bash and latec work uses Comiga. Full and proper use of Comiga requires poly mode.
Let's call that poly Comiga. But EMAX's poly mode is working progress,
particularly now with the new three-sitter. So in the interim, my usage of Comiga has been
in the form of toggle Comiga, where I manually switch between the programming mode and org mode.
For me, this has proved to be a fine interim solution.
Yes. In EMAX, the way that we have been dealing with documentation and information retrieval
is archaic. Man pages taken for helpful mode and convention-based doc strings are old and limited.
In BISOS and BLEE, we use BLEE panels for all kinds of documentation. Let me show you some examples.
Two fundamental autonomy oriented capabilities that by store offers to individuals are
email and content generation and publication. I'll give a quick overview of these two important
capabilities. At the EMAX CONF 2022, the title of my presentation was revisiting the anatomy of
EMAX male user agents. In that presentation, I gave a brief overview of BISOS, Mormie,
multi-account resident male exchange environment, and Bleegnose. In BISOS, these are typically
paired with byname.net autonomous email services. Content production and self-publication
is a foundational BLEE and BISOS capability bundle. Both this presentation and the nature of
PODY Existentials book were developed with BLEE LCNT. The original text is always in
Comiga latex, latex augmented by org mode. This is the inverse direction of exporting latex from
org mode. For typesetting, the latex syntax is far more powerful than org mode, and with
Comiga latex, you can also benefit from all that org mode offers. For presentation, screen
casting, the original text is then augmented in layers by images, audio voiceovers,
screen captures, videos, and captions. The BML latex file is then processed by both
latex and heavier. Latex produced slides are then absorbed in HTML by heavier as images.
Heavya is a latex to HTML converter. Heavya output is destined to be dispensed by reveal.js.
This video is just a screen capture of the autoplay of reveal file.
Viewing this presentation in its original revamped form is a very rich experience.
All of this involves a whole lot of integration scripting. In raw BISOS, these scripts are in
BISOS Core LCNT bin.
To say that BISOS and BLE or big-and-ambition is an understatement, and clearly, a small theme
won't be able to deliver the outlandish blueprint that is outlined in the nature of Polly Existentials book.
We have been at this for over two decades, and we feel that now, in 2024, it makes sense to involve you.
The pointer has an instructions for installation and usage of BISOS and BLE that I have provided.
Produced systems that are minimally functional, but are not cleaned.
At this time, don't expect stability and support.
Throughout this presentation, I have been emphasizing service portability and possession
ascertainable labor services, PALS. But a complete digital ecosystem includes various other types of
Internet application services as well. In this slide, PALS are at the center and are then augmented
by different other types of services. In the BISOS Store model, equivalent of Facebook-style
application services are called inter-autonomous interactions. With individual-oriented PALS in
place using OAuth of PALS, resources can be shared. Based on that, we can then structure inter-autonomous
interactions while preserving much privacy. Any blueprint for a digital ecosystem must also
consider the economic and business dimensions. Chapter 13, Polly Existential Capitalism
delves into proper economic models for Polly Existentials. The concept of attribution-based
economics, which has been discussed in this forum before, is included.
Chapter 21, Private Sector Strategies by Store Open Business Plan
deals with the business dimension of PALS. What if, in addition to being ethics-oriented,
the entirety of this book could also be considered a sophisticated business plan?
Are there any venture capitalists that use EMAX?
Here is a set of relatively complete domains and links for digging deeper.
These pointers are structured in four layers, ideologies, software, services, and guardianship.
If BISOS, by Store Libre Hallol and Polly Existentials have picked your interest,
and if you wish to participate in making these ideas more widespread and want to further cultivate
them, here are some suggestions. The examples of the bleak concepts that I chose were
purposeful and targeted. I'm hopeful that Orgmo developers and EMAX developers would recognize that
it makes good sense to expand the scope of Org dynamic blocks to the entirety of EMAX.
I'm hopeful that the concept of Polly mode, a single buffer with regions in different modes,
and Orgmo in particular, would receive a high priority in our three-seater transition.
I'm hopeful that bleak omega can become a generalized form of Polly mode.
I'm hopeful that we can build on bleak panels and move towards having a richer base for a universal
EMAX documentation framework. If participation in any of these is of interest to you,
please feel welcome to contact me. EMAX conferences have proven to be very useful and productive.
I look forward to your thoughts, feedback, and questions.
I want to thank all the EMAX conferences for their great work. I'm Sasha, Leo, and Amin, in particular.